[Música]
bom alguém aqui já fala de mim e davi
sesa
eu luto pouco trabalho aliás no meu
objetivo é trabalhar contra o a barreira
atitudinal a barreira atitudinal na
temática da pessoa com deficiência
nós temos aqui algumas pessoas com
deficiência talvez é a temática da
pessoa com deficiência da barreira
atitudinal ela é talvez a raiz do
problema da do preconceito
ela é a raiz da das discussões sobre a
pessoa com deficiência porque se nós
se nós temos dentro de uma sociedade a
barreira atitudinal aí já começa o
problema de todas as outras barreiras a
barreira informacional a barreira
arquitetônica a barreira educacional
alguém que arrisca dizer o que a
barreira atitudinal a barreira
atitudinal pelo nome você pode perceber
que vem pela atitude pelo comportamento
pela desinformação
nossa olha o davi braços e as pernas
tanto que ele superou tanto que ele
conquistou
nossa que guerrero adoro gente mas isso
às vezes costuma ser chato
a barreira atitudinal é muita
desinformação também aí como eu vou
lidar com aquela pessoa com deficiência
aliás fazer aqui o termômetro é sobre a
inclusão
muitas pessoas dizem que eu falo enterro
técnico dentro da empresa mesmo é
portadora de necessidades especiais
gente eu adoro ser uma pessoa especial
que eu quero ser nosso sincero mesmo
quero é especial mas não é a pessoa com
deficiência olha só
nós criamos uma condição de pessoa
a sociedade ainda tem muito o que
trabalhar sobre o tema da pessoa com
deficiência
em um dado uma pesquisa dos da
secretaria de direitos humanos da
presidência da república que fala que
96% da população diz que não existe é
discriminação que existe igualdade entre
pessoas que têm deficiência a pessoa que
não têm deficiência
em contrapartida
quando estamos na rua quando colocamos
esse corpo a na rua as pessoas com os
olhares
a gente já vê o desconhecimento vocês já
ouviram falar sobre a síndrome do
shopping center
a medição no facebook que é uma tese que
eu criei essa síndrome do chão do
shopping center
é ela começa pelos olhares das pessoas
os olhares de estranhamento eu tô no
shopping talvez o shopping o mundo das
aparências sabe onde talvez não existe
diferença dentro do shopping onde
acontece mais olhares e as pessoas
começam a olhar de lado
curiosa eu vou passar a comer cadeirinha
quando eu sento na à mesa para comer eu
comer sozinho praticando a minha
autonomia nossa você começou assim como
a pessoa já começa a olhar mais ainda
assim a síndrome do shopping center lapa
piora quando o ser humano aquele cidadão
chega até mim fala que acontece é o c b
e minerais né que aconteceu com silvério
gente eu descobri que quando fala que eu
nasci assim em causa uma frustração das
pessoas é de verdade uma frustração
talvez acho que o ser humano gosta de
sangue né
ele está esperando aquela tragédia
portásio tudo e comecei a brincar com a
situação que aconteceu com você meu caro
estava na praia vi um tubarão de um lado
o tubarão do outro
meu deus eu não gosto de brincar com a
tragédia não li mas isso aí é uma uma
estratégia que eu uso para quebrar o
gelo com as pessoas sabe aí que é pra
quebrar exatamente essa barreira
atitudinal eu uso o humor eu também
tenho uma apresentação de stand up eu
uso um humor pra quebrar é essa barreira
atitudinal trazer a pessoa perto mas é a
pessoa para o meu mundo não sei
uma vez um amigo aqui na cidade de belo
horizonte ele estava numa rádio e ele
podia rádio questionou pra ele lá no
lugar nessa cidade que não tem
acessibilidade na vida noturna ele não
sei por que você tá com davi ele vai
saber melhor ligar para um amigo que é
de vida noturna eu vou ligar pra ele vai
explicar melhor quais lugares são mais
inacessíveis
eu não queria falar o nome de lugares e
ele pegou a pessoa errada então ligou à
rádio telefone comigo alô olá davi você
está ao vivo na rádio x muito boa tarde
olá boa tarde davi nós temos uma coisa
para te perguntar qual o lugar da sua
cidade não tem acessibilidade gente eu
sei pensar eu estou com a cabeça no
lugar certo você pensar falei pra eles
motel
o assunto esperando a sexualidade com
pessoa com deficiência um tabu tamanho
não acredite falo isso dá mais é mais a
viu eu quando vou lá eu tenho que pegar
três horas uma hora para subir uma hora
para descansar em uma hora vai embora é
tanto significado que as pessoas colocam
e aí então elas muitas pessoas
perguntavam então tá da av
você tá aí com essa carinha sua
empoderada o que é a melhor ferramenta
para trabalhar o preconceito quando a
pessoa com deficiência ou discriminação
o que melhor ferramenta pra gente
trabalhar a inclusão não sei talvez o
diálogo um diálogo sério
primeiro que você não vai chegar a
pessoas a falar olá pessoa com
deficiência tudo bem da sua defesa
a jóia não o primeiro tem um nome da
pessoa é o lado a ver como vai a bola eu
não tenho experiência de lidar e não tem
não tive na minha família a desculpa da
av
como eu posso te ajudar quem você
precisa de alguma orientação você
precisa de algum acir
aí você já tá quebrando causando o
futuro aliás
você tá fazendo da você está inserindo
sim aquela pessoa que você está
conversando é o diálogo
a iam conhece de diálogo e aqui navio
mãe de uma das meninas aqui na cidade
eu vi um cervo querendo atravessar a rua
o deficiente visual segue querendo
atravessar a rua eu falei a já pouca
experiência basta o diálogo né
atravessei a rua pois ninguém está
ajudando os cara vou ter que ajudar
valeu boa tarde boa tarde porque seu
nome não lembro o nome dele
ele é precária eu vou te ajudar
nós vamos atravessar a rua e ele
respondeu aqui ótimo tava doido pra
atravessar me dá amor que nós vamos nós
temos um probleminha que amigo amiguinho
não tem mãozinha
eu vou virar a cadeira de rodas pra você
o estupro dentro e chutou em cima de uma
cadeira de rodas
então eu tinha que escrever olha só
descrever o cego eu vou virar a cadeira
de rodas pra você for ficar de frente é
você sabe o guidão da cadeira você vai
se apoiar nos cidadãos e nós vamos
atravessar seja o que deus quiser nós
vamos embora
levei o sérvio para a faixa de pedestre
gente eu não sei em outra cidade mas em
belo horizonte acontece muito isso já
virou aquele semáforos em mal fechou já
tive a oportunidade você também já abriu
então eu fui consegue atravessar a rua
me der o ok lá o sinal de ok pode
atravessar semáforo me deu aquele gol
pode atravessar mas quando eu coloquei o
pega aliás a roda da cadeira de rodas na
faixa de pedestre
o sérvio apoiado na cadeira sinal do
semáforo já começou a buscar eu já
pensei comigo minha nossa senhora eu vou
morrer aqui junto com o cego já deve
estar de prontidão aquele jornalista
sensacionalistas né
já deve tá em cima do viaduto plantá-la
deficiente morre tentando ajudar cego na
rua
eu atravessei mas realmente gente o
diálogo é quando a gente é consegue
quando você não tem essa experiência
talvez o diálogo é a melhor receita
vocês sabiam que o mercado de trabalho é
muito preconceituoso
ainda dentro da de um cotidiano da
cidade de uma vivência de uma pessoa com
deficiência existe existem muitos
preconceitos existem os olhares nos
desafiam muito êxito no mercado de
trabalho a oportunidade
dentro de tudo isso da nossa construção
a gente aprender a lidar com tudo isso
aqui fora
tem também os nossos a nossa família
a aceitação o recebimento de uma pessoa
com a família dentro de uma família uma
pessoa com deficiência dentro de uma
família tem escola em 1996 devem
procurar uma escola aqui nessa cidade e
diz ela que recebeu vários nãos para me
colocar nessa cidade
nessa escola aliás vários nãos um desses
nãos uma mãe chegou até a minha mãe
falou assim olha eu não sou
preconceituosa não gente já viu a pessoa
mais preconceituosa
essa pessoa mais preconceituosa que se
move com a vírgula
eu não sou preconceituoso não mas
criança é maldosa gente criança maldosa
eles vão olhar aí pro davi vamos ter
mais tato tartaruguinha pinguim
eu já pensei comigo a dor é esse apelido
é nossa amiga
só que o maior dilema dentro de uma
escola bullying essa é uma segurança da
minha mãe
com o tempo ela conseguiu colocar na
escola e ali era o que a lei fala muito
hoje até onde vai a autonomia dessa
pessoa com deficiência dessa pessoa que
tem deficiência uma escola regular
recebeu meu filho que a escola regular
escolas que comporta pessoas com
deficiência sem deficiência
então eu tava no convívio comum é o que
minha mãe queria quando ela me colocou
naquela escola no primeiro dia de aula
no quem convive com um primeiro dia ela
é insegura ela se escondeu atrás o
escaninho atrás de um armário que tinha
no fundo da sala e ela lá dentro daquela
sala no fundo da sala ela prestando
atenção como seria a reação dos meninos
deu 3 40 da tarde o recreio chegaram
quatro linhas e rodrigo tiago valter
aproximaram de mim me levar até para me
ajudar a comer ela aliviou a agora
começa uma vida do davi sozinho ele não
depende mais de mim eu mãe nova que com
17 anos descobri uma gravidez de um
filho com deficiência e mãe solteira
agora o davi está provocando a autonomia
dele agora eu posso preocupar também com
a minha vida
não quero preocupar só com o meu filho
eu quero ter minha vida os meus sonhos é
a mãe pensava eu entrei dentro da eu
entrei na escola e lá as pessoas
perguntam você não teve nenhuma
dificuldade dentro da escola tirar o
português matemática geografia história
se ela já pelo time dificuldade nenhuma
gente que as pessoas querem saber tudo
do zero preconceito as pessoas não sei
através apenas maldosa maldade na cabeça
tem preconceito não
eu não tenho isso pra contar dentro da
minha história
os meninos me receberam quando eles
receberam naquela cadeira de rodas e
ajudar a comer minha mãe percebeu já não
estava mais na cadeira tinham acertado a
cabeça em baixo para cima na rua
ele começou meu mundo 100 de autonomia
sem depender da minha mãe onde muitos
falavam juliana davi vai depender de
você 24 horas por dia
então fiz a primeira série e segurança é
a terceira e quarta séries 5ª série 5ª
série 7000 da série meus amigos era tão
apaixonados por mim que tomava bomba
junto gente vai pode ir embora criatura
não nos vão ficar
e ele na segunda vez que eu repetir um
ano veio aquele conflito da adolescência
já passaram por isso que conflitos do
concurso da adolescência e sexualidade
eu cheguei com um amigo não tem
referência masculina nenhum outro dentro
da família
cheguei para um amigo muito seguro e
ouvia todos os meus amigos namorando
cheguei para ele e para mim o seguinte
cara um dia vou poder namorar alguém vai
olhar para minha profissão me apaixonar
porque como diz o lucas eu sou um
partidão hoje eu tenho certeza disso
o henrique é prontamente respondeu para
mim porque eu estava pedindo um conselho
de um menino de 15 anos mas era a única
figura masculina e talvez eu conhecia
que a proximidade
ele olhou pra mim e disse aquele jeitão
dele árabe pelo amor de deus e nunca
reclamou de nada agora vai começar a
reclamar vão acontecer vai acontecer no
futuro mas também pronto acabou
só que quando eu tentava me acalmar
dessa maneira dele
ele teve um insight e que gente é amigo
quando têm sites e sai correndo estava
preso na cadeia
ele olhou pra mim falou
[Música]
você nasceu com qual síndrome mesmo um
símbolo de rake o peso do indicativo de
uma vida então você pega um nome novo
nossa nós vamos pesquisar e nos
deparamos com essa síndrome atinge 17
pessoas vulneráveis à plataforma
muito obrigado pela sorte do mds né o
darwin e dentro dessas sete pessoas no
mundo nós vamos encontrar aquela que tem
sido a de renato
você vai ligar pra ela vai dizer olá
tudo bem eu sou seu prometido
eu também tenho um símbolo de raça pura
coincidência
eu vou te buscar a cavalo de uma cadeira
de rodas gente e depois da pesquisa não
contra ninguém mas em nós por nós de
forma genuína e em géneros que éramos
também nós pesquisamos mesmo nas festas
eu ganhei um carro na minha vida
henrique chegava para as meninas toró de
vela nível fica sentadinho lina na
frente dele
isso demonstra respeito
agora olha para o rosto dele até que ele
é bonitinho e suor mas é uma grande
ideia piorou os sites da visa ganhar
muito dinheiro nós vamos ter que arrumar
alguém vai ganhar muito dinheiro aqui
porque nós vamos encontrar essa pessoa
ainda nós vamos encontrar você vai
escrever um livro
olha o nome desse mundo
vai pegar esse dinheiro vai chamar
ninguém segura esse bebê
às vezes eu fico preocupado com o nome
certo na vida que estão comigo até hoje
23 anos amizade
só que é o que eu quero passar por isso
para vocês
nessa convivência é que essas pessoas e
oportunizar a viver de oportunizar a
estudar os professores ele na escola
regular lá no início talvez não sabiam
como lidar também em uma sociedade que
ainda é muito nova o assunto é inclusão
da pessoa com deficiência existe muito
desconhecimento
em primeiro lugar a gente precisa
quebrar essa barreira atitudinal o
primeiro lugar a gente precisa se
aproximar e conhecer um pouco
os dilemas as possibilidades que basta
oportuniza que a gente desenvolve a
nossa autonomia
a palavra chave para mim hoje da pessoa
com deficiência autonomia como provocar
autonomia daquela pessoa ensino médio se
terminar o ensino médio e da faculdade
curso de direito o quinto período com o
direito de matá-lo
davi talita foi demitida você vai ter
que pagar seu console são joão
procure emprego meu filho aí eu caí
achando que arrumar emprego então vou
esperar o meu currículo né você
encontrar rapidamente e não preciso
ganhar muito com essa vaga na faculdade
o resto não me ajuda aí ela falou que eu
poderia me ajudar
então parei meu currículo ninguém ligava
eu tirei um detalhe do meu currículo que
tinha deficiência um lugar me ligou e
falou assim davi
temos uma vaga pra você vai eu soubesse
já não tem mais não desligou
só que continue a procura o outro lugar
uma agência bancária gigante no brasil
você olha só nós vamos contar pela
pessoa com deficiência é uma vaga mas
vem aqui processo seletivo e eu com a
minha cabeça preconceituosa pensei a uma
vaga só vai hoje é minha gente
porque olha só eu sou bonito
beleza faz parte de contratação a minha
cabeça
e no penta do deficiente assim na cidade
do contratado
naquele processo seletivo aqui o salão
estava tomada de pessoas 120 pessoas
estão aqui não é que não há profissional
é resgatá lo é sabe a síndrome do
shopping center que os olhares me
desafiam agora fui eu com as pessoas
porque olhava o cidadão que estava
sentado no processo seletivo
eu só como dívida tinha esse dom que vem
do meu lado vou ver nenhuma eu curioso
eu pendi da onde vem a curiosidade na
gente viu lá não vou ter que perguntar
olá tudo bem já está no processo
seletivo também tô aqui de tudo certo
é preciso perguntar vai perguntar o que
você tem é que ele respondeu com uma
autoestima que ok é esse cara é bem
resolvido mesmo quem sou eu
eu tenho dois centímetros e meio da
perna direita maior que a perna esquerda
eu sou de humanas o que calculamos que
os 86 olhei pra ele responde op
parabéns desde então são mutantes pronto
para ser executado até agora
a gente bota 20 segundos para encerrar é
o que a gente precisa mesmo é dar
oportunidade e simplesmente utilizar e
com diálogo a gente vai se aproximando
entendendo quais são as necessidades se
é que tem algumas cidades nós precisamos
mesmo é quebrar a barreira atitudinal
nós precisamos mesmo é nos informar mais
sobre a pessoa com deficiência e para
que colocar esse público nós que temos
deficiência cada vez mais protagonista
dentro de uma sociedade e não pessoas
encostadas só para cumprir cotton
obrigado
um abraço
[Aplausos]